comme vous savez sans doute le 24
février au matin la russie a attaquent
l'ukraine avec notamment des
bombardements et des transgressions de
fond de serre et dans ce contexte
extrêmement préoccupant je pense qu'il
est urgent pour chacun d'entre nous de
se demander si l'on peut aider et
comment on peut aider
sachant que
des millions d'ukrainiens sont
actuellement en grave danger donc si on
peut faire un petit quelque chose pour
aider
je pense qu'il faut le faire
et selon le prix nobel de la paix écrit
mouratov dans des aspects très
importants de ce conflit c'est le
soutient encore à poutine en interne
pour conduire cette guerre est bien la
bonne nouvelle c'est que malgré le fait
que poutine a interdit de tels
rassemblements anti guerre il y a en ce
moment en russie énormément de
protestation contre poutine et il faut
le prendre en compte du courage
absolument formidable de ces personnes
qui sont en train de mettre leur vie en
péril pour pouvoir lutter contre des
oscars et de potentiel de guerre et de
souffrance dans des pays étrangers
je ne peux qu apporter mon soutien et
j'aimerais inviter chacun d'entre vous a
apporté à votre tour votre soutien de
tels mouvements en laye quand en
partageant en 28 ans en parlant de ces
russes extrêmement courageux qui sont
prêts à risquer leur vie pour demander
la fin de la guerre et qui pourrait
potentiellement même conduire à des
changements de régime dans cette
dictature qui pourrait ensuite permettre
d'éviter davantage d'escaladé qui
pourrait conduire à des guerres
peut-être plus horrible encore entre des
superpuissances voir une guerre mondiale
la russie jeu mené jusque là une info
guerre une guerre de l'information
extrêmement efficace il est urgent que
l'on riposte que chacun d'entre nous
prenne un peu de notre temps personnel
pour au moins soutenir ceux qui
s'opposent publiquement à la guerre